[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOBY OLIE: Yes, my name's Toby.
I'm the Puppetry
Director and Puppet
Co-designer for "Pinocchio"
at the National Theatre.
Audrey plays Jiminy
Cricket, does the voice,
and is one half of
the puppeteering team.
And James is the other half
of the puppeteering team.
And our show is quite unique.
And very near sort
of the beginning
of the inception
of the show, it was
decided that Pinocchio would
be the only human onstage.
And everybody else
would be a puppet.
So characters like
Geppetto and Stromboli
are all 12 foot high puppets.
So the scale is really
shifted in Pinocchio's favor
and so the audience kind of see
the world through Pinocchio's
eyes.
And Jiminy Cricket
originally was a bit
of a sort of question mark.
It's such a kind of
iconic character really.
You know, in the
Disney branding,
Jiminy is part of the
theme park branding.
It's on the beginning of DVDs.
He's pretty essential
to that kind of image.
And so there was
a lot of questions
as to how loyal we should be
to the original animated film,
or how much we should
go in another direction.
And I suppose I was looking to
see if we could have our cake
and eat it, really.
And the first few
drafts of the script
had the character being
very much more insect-like.
It referenced the
character having more arms
than just the two arms, two legs
that the Disney character has.
There was no reference
to the character
wearing clothes or a little top
hat like it does in the film.
So it sort of felt right
to go for a more insect.
So it's worth saying
as well that Jiminy
is female in our version.
Hence Audrey.
AUDREY BRISSON: Yes.
TOBY OLIE: Which came
sort of brilliantly out
of the development process.
But we'll talk a little
about that shortly.
So initially I kind of
began to go back and look
at the original source material.
Lots of the original
concept drawings
for Jiminy, different
expressions, and just
began immersed into what
creative process led
Disney to end up with Jiminy
the way he looks in the film.
I was quite obsessed by
his proportions as well.
And as you'll see later on,
if the proportions are out,
he ends up looking a bit like
a grasshopper, not cricket.
So I quite liked the sort of
three heads high kind of vibe.
And so the final puppets ended
up sort of closer towards that.
So the first drawing in my
sketchbook, which I think
was while someone
was having a meeting
and was being quite
important, and I
have a very bad habit for
doodling during people talking.
But that's normally when
the good stuff happens.
Yeah.
It was very much kind
of insect, six legs,
had backwards knees on this
one, and the wings hanging down
like a little coat tail like
the character has in the film.
But sort of keeping the kind
of nose, little kind of old man
kind of mouth that the character
has from the animated film.
I felt like, in my head
when I picture Jiminy,
I thought like, oh, he's
got a little green pea head,
and he's got that sort
of little pinched mouth.
So I thought keeping
that is quite
a nice nod to the original.
I got obsessed with
the shape of his head
and start drawing it from
all different angles.
Whether the antennae go
forward or they go back.
There's lots of other animated
movies with insects in.
I didn't want Jiminy to look
like she was from any of those.
And so various kind
of little details.
Eye proportion.
If they're too big,
she looks like a fly.
She looked too small,
she looked like a sort
of human version of a bug.
Various different things.
And so "Pinocchio"
was in development
for a number of years.
And the National Theatre
has this amazing building,
the National Theatre Studio,
which sort of incorporates
the new work department.
And shows that are
being pitched--
they're not even
commissioned yet--
get developed in this building.
And so that's where
scripts are drafted.
It's where workshops are held
with actors and directors,
and where you sort of pitch the
shows to the National Theatre.
And "Pinocchio"
was sort of still
being commissioned, per se.
It hadn't been given
the full green light.
And so I did three
development workshops there,
deciding on the scale
of the bigger puppets--
making a giant
cardboard Geppetto
and then that turned
to a foam one.
And then eventually it
sort of evolved through.
And in the second
workshop, the big sort
of question we'd
all been avoiding
was, how's Jiminy
Cricket going to work?
Is it going to be an actor?
In my head as soon
as someone said
that, I was like, oh,
someone in a big lime
green kind of onesie, with
some like green hoppers on.
Yeah.
An actor in a costume.
Is it objects from
Geppetto's workshop
that the fairy kind of conjures
together to be an insect,
or is it a puppet character?
And I being a massive
puppet nerd since I was six,
and making puppets things, I was
like, if Jiminy Cricket isn't
a puppet, I've not
done my job right.
Let's kind of go for it.
And so we were casting
this development workshop.
And in those kind of situations,
it's always quite nice
to have a mix of people you
have and haven't worked with.
And in the case of
puppetry, I'm always
a big fan of going right with
people who've had experience,
so no one is learning on
the job over five days,
how to puppeteer something as
complicated as Jiminy Cricket.
If ultimately, the
decisions about that process
are going to be made
in those five days,
let's have some kind
of common ground.
Audrey and I have done a
number of projects together,
but the main one being the
"Elephantom" adaptation
of a children's book
at The National.
And James and I have done
far too many things together.
JAMES CHARLTON: Too many.
TOBY OLIE: "Light
Princess" at The National
and "Little Shop of Horrors" in
Manchester, and "Running Yeah.
Too many things.
And so it was really exciting
that actually these guys,
we'd had puppetry
experience together.
That they could kind of
hit the ground running.
So we made a prototype,
which you can see here.
It was an upside down
plastic bleach bottle.
It was full sort of
"Blue Peter" making mode.
And some plastic plumbing
pipe and cardboard
and polystyrene for the head.
It was really quickly
thrown together
to sort of try out the ideas.
And so I think the
idea was that we would
run a scene with the puppet.
We'd run the same
scene with an actor.
And we'd run the same
scene with sort of objects
or a kind of abstracted
thing on the actor's arm,
and see which one people
related to the most.
And thankfully we
started with the puppet,
because we never needed
to try the other two.
Because people were
ludicrously spellbound,
which was really,
really brilliant.
It remains one of
my favorite days
of my career, people's response
to this puppet in the room.
And the work these guys did in--
I don't know.
You sort of had
probably, two half days,
and then we ended up
showing the scene to people.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
And it wasn't always our
primary focus either.
There were some things going on.
So you sort of get thrown
this puppet and, off you go.
And you're like, OK, we've
got to show people now
if it's good.
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
Yeah.
And John and the rest
of the creative team--
there was never a question,
really, about gender
being an issue with Jiminy.
There are so few
female characters
in the original Disney movie.
I think there's just the fairy,
the more I think about it.
It's just the Blue Fairy.
And she comes in and is very
ethereal and is very 1940s.
When did it come out?
Late '30s?
No.
You know, she's very of
that time-- very moralistic.
And she leaves.
And so John and
Dennis the writer
were really keen to
have some much, much
stronger female presence in
the show, as well as the Blue
Fairy.
And actually, Jimmy just
immediately presented herself
as being a really
great candidate for it.
Audrey is too modest
to say it, so I should.
She has very good comic timing.
And she's an amazing singer.
Not as good comic
timing in real life.
AUDREY BRISSON:
Not in real life.
TOBY OLIE: But on stage.
On stage, it's a lot better.
And so these two kind
of worked their magic
with this bit of cardboard
and plastic bottle.
And the sort of go ahead
for the puppet was given.
So probably, four or
five months later--
the prototype was December 2016?
AUDREY BRISSON: Yes.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yes.
TOBY OLIE: And so probably
May, April time 2017,
we started to think about
what she might look like.
Googling crickets.
I had no idea there were so many
different kinds of crickets.
There were some
freaky looking things
like camouflaged ones, ones
that were like hideous aliens.
I quite liked the
sort of top left one
that looks like it is
standing on its back legs.
And from those kind of
things it was like, oh yeah,
her knees should point forwards.
They shouldn't point back
like a real cricket's,
because it's a bit too
sci-fi kind of weirdy.
Let's try and make
it a bit relatable.
So I kind of, yeah,
started to draw.
She's sort of four
heads high, this one.
A sort of more insect-y
looking cricket with the kind
of slight anthropomorphic
human sort
of layout of the Disney film.
It just looked too sci-fi.
It didn't feel-- it felt
a bit like "District 9."
I mean, where people start
turning into the shrimp aliens.
It felt a bit like that.
A bit sort of too, I don't know.
Yeah.
Just a bit too
science experiment-y.
And so John the director,
and Bob Crowley,
who designed the
set and costumes
and co-designed the puppets
with me, he just said,
don't go too far
from what you've got.
What you had really worked.
Don't over-engineer it.
And so we kept the
nod to the bottle.
And her body is sort of a
kind of upside down apothecary
bottle kind of shape, with
these sort of sections in it
to give her kind of an
exoskeleton kind of shape.
And yeah.
All of her limbs--
I just kind of went more with
kind of curves, or thinking
about having little sleeves
that looked sort of exoskeleton.
They're so segmented.
But I kind of thought of
little sleeves or little cuffs.
Or if her legs are
so kind of curvy,
going in different
directions, and it gives her
a kind of rounded,
sort of friendly vibe,
but still sort of creates
insect kind of feeling.
And yeah.
The head proportions
are a bit bigger by now.
And I'm thinking about
how the joints would work.
She's got elastic in her
legs that you'll see,
which means she's very springy.
But this was the
sort of blueprint
that we ended up, that
I gave to the makers.
So we do a sort of side
profile, and front profile.
And then this was blown
up to exact scale.
And then this amazing maker,
Roy, started to carve her.
And so he carved all the
elements out of blue Styrofoam.
It's quite rigid.
And it's a bit like polystyrene,
but doesn't sort of flake away.
And you can take molds from it.
It's quite good and sturdy.
And so he started
sculpting the head.
This is probably about the
third test of the head.
I got really pedantic
about the shape of eyes
and how jowly she was.
Things like that.
But yeah.
It took a few sculpts
of the head, eyebrow.
Whether her eyebrows
looked too angry.
And various things like that.
And so head was
sculpted in foam.
Hands were sculpted in foam.
And they were covered.
And made molds of.
Because we knew we wanted more
than one puppet for the show.
The puppet gets
quite a long workout.
She's probably the puppet that's
on stage the most in the show,
right?
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
That or Geppetto.
Between them, they
probably share.
TOBY OLIE: Though Geppetto's not
jumping around as much, is he?
JAMES CHARLTON:
That's true, too.
TOBY OLIE: So we knew
we wanted more than one.
And if things broke,
then it's great to have
a means of just making
another arm or leg,
so molding her, and being
able to make duplicates
felt really valuable.
AUDREY BRISSON:
Which was very useful
in the rehearsal process.
TOBY OLIE: Oh yeah.
Yeah, go on about the
rehearsal process.
AUDREY BRISSON: So
we were doing a run.
I think it was our first run.
And there's a moment
when the Fox attempts
to kill Jiminy with an ax.
TOBY OLIE: Spoiler alert.
AUDREY BRISSON: Oh.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CHARLTON:
Have to know now.
AUDREY BRISSON: Well, in doing
so, chops his own tail off.
And the actor, David
Langham, who plays the Fox,
did it with such gusto, and
had been given a new ax--
TOBY OLIE: Still a prop.
But still quite heavy.
AUDREY BRISSON: Still
a prop but very heavy.
And he went with such
force and conviction
and chopped one of her legs off.
But I didn't notice.
And so the reaction--
JAMES CHARLTON: Because
you were so in the--
AUDREY BRISSON: Because
I was in the moment.
The reaction of the
audience, the creatives,
were just, oh, oh my God, what's
happened, what's happened.
And I just said, wow,
they're very into the scene.
[LAUGHTER]
They're so [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES CHARLTON: I
think between us,
we were absolutely mortified.
And we sort of went over to
Toby and went, it's all right.
We've got spares.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBY OLIE: And it is.
It's like a pit stop.
You can literally sort of go,
leg goes on, leg goes off.
But ax attacks aside,
we knew that she
was going to have some
wear and tear in the show.
So her legs and arms
and hands are all
molded in fast cast, which
is sort of crazy resistant.
You can throw it on the floor.
It doesn't shatter.
Feels quite sort
of like porcelain.
It feels sort of quite
dense kind of china.
And we filled it with this
crazy expanding stuff that's
sort of like glass bubbles.
So actually she is sort
of like an aero inside.
She's aerated, with
this very solid outside,
which is massively resistant.
And then her head and her
body are fiberglass from mold.
So she can really
kind of take a knock.
But yeah.
All of her numerous arms and her
legs and feet coming together.
And so by the time
we got to rehearsals,
we did a week of puppet
training, didn't we,
prior to full-time rehearsals
with the rest of the company.
Because in the show we've
got five puppets in total.
Jiminy, Geppetto, Blue Fairy,
Stromboli, Coachman-- oh,
and the whale.
Six.
The whale is enormous.
But yeah.
So we had a week
of puppet training
so that the people working in
teams of two or three or four
could work together to
animate the characters.
And so throughout rehearsals,
we had very nearly
finished the finished
Jiminy, which
is great, because it means you
can sort of road test things.
If there's any alterations
to handles or grip tape.
Various things that
you can kind of
keep adding and playing with.
And so we did a
majority of rehearsals
with one of our two
Jiminys in unfinished form.
And yeah.
Getting up to
hijinks and kind of
beginning to find their kind of
duet on this puppet together.
So lots of questions
were being bandied around
about what her finish would be.
And it felt quite nice
to sort of give her
a slight fantastical quality.
So in the Disney movie, Jiminy
turns up at the beginning.
And he's just there.
And he's wearing clothes.
He happens upon
Geppetto's workshop.
And the Blue Fairy says,
you're Pinocchio's conscience.
And the story continues.
And in Dennis'
script, the Blue Fairy
turns sort of a real cricket--
which, on stage,
is kind of mimed,
and people see it
jumping around.
And there's a sound effect.
She transforms the
kind of actual cricket
into a bigger, more kind
of humanoid cricket,
which is our puppet.
And so to give her this
sort of fantastical quality,
I began to look at
other insects that
had kind of fantastical
wing colors, shell colors.
And so there's a
jewel beetle that
come in all sorts of colors
and shapes and sizes.
And, yeah.
This sort of green that sort
of turns blue in places,
or it turns red.
Just thought that
was really brilliant.
Give her a real kind of
cosmic sort of sheen.
As you can see, the final
puppet doesn't have this.
So there is a story to tell.
But we researched
this amazing paint
that's called flip-flop
paint that's used
a lot of motorbikes, on cars.
And it does shift.
So the shadowier side
is a different color
to the side that's
in direct light.
We were like, brilliant.
She's going to look amazing.
Yeah, it's kind of
an expensive paint.
Yeah, it takes 12 different
coats of spraying,
and it takes four weeks.
Whatever.
We'll do it.
It's going to be great.
Create some really
fancy concept art.
Everybody loved it.
Great.
Brilliant.
[LAUGHTER]
Puppet arrived.
Oh my God, it's like Christmas.
It looks amazing.
Oh, and they put
red on the bottom.
One bit.
Ah, gosh, she looks brilliant.
Ah, let's thread
it together, yeah.
Oh, God, it's great.
It's like Iron Man, but a bug.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh yeah, cool.
Yeah, it's fantastic.
Yeah, let's put it onstage.
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
It was so disappointing.
It's the first day of
technical rehearsals.
So we were five days in tech?
AUDREY BRISSON: Five
days in tech, yeah.
TOBY OLIE: So you
have rehearsals
in the rehearsal room.
And you go into
technical rehearsals
where you're onstage.
And yes, the cast is
still kind of rehearsing,
but it's more about adapting to
the space, putting in lighting,
putting in sound.
There's a lot of
illusions in "Pinocchio."
There's some flying.
And so there was a lot
of technical things
to put in place.
And Jiminy just sort
of wasn't a worry
until she turns up
under the table.
And all you can see is Audrey
staring into some sort of--
AUDREY BRISSON: Which
is a nice thing.
TOBY OLIE: A sort of black
VW Beetle that she's holding.
I don't know, yeah.
She didn't reflect light at all.
She didn't reflect any light.
She sort of absorbed it.
All the darker tones
kind of came out.
And she sort of just looked
like she was always in shadow.
And people who have seen the
show comment on how brilliant
it is being able to see Audrey
and James do their thing
and how they relate
to the puppet.
But ultimately, if you can't
see the puppet in darkness,
and you can see the
puppeteer staring at nothing,
we're kind of not
doing our jobs right.
So, frantic on my
phone, image searching
different kinds of cricket,
brighter color palettes.
Things that could
be really zingy.
There's not a lot
of set in Pinocchio.
Very often Jiminy is performed
on a sort of dark canvas.
And so the fact that she
could be quite bright
would really help show her
silhouette and all the kind
of detail that you
guys were doing,
that you just couldn't see with
the shinier, darker puppet.
Some crazy bright green fellows.
Getting the old Pantone app out.
We're going through, comparing,
finding the right kind of tone.
Because there's a weird thing.
You're straight into a kind
of acid trip crazy neon green
too easily.
And it was quite
interesting to find
the kind of very bright lime
shade that would kind of work
and still feel natural, without
being too kind of cosmic.
I got my coloring pencils
out on my tech desk,
while we're still
carrying on with the show.
AUDREY BRISSON:
Look at that, yeah.
We only had three days
or something [INAUDIBLE]
before we had the photo
shoots on that Wednesday.
And I think that was a Saturday
when we were told that Jiminy--
TOBY OLIE: It was mad.
So because we had
two puppets, yeah.
Thank you.
That's worth saying.
We had two puppets.
And one of them
had been sprayed.
And this other one had been
sent to this amazing custom
motorcyclist to start.
And as soon as we saw this, I
was like, get him on the phone.
Stop him.
So we called up.
And he'd brilliantly-- he'd
sanded her down, primed her.
She was totally
ready for painting.
He hadn't started the motorbike
paint, which was perfect.
So we were like, you've
done a great job.
We just don't want to
proceed any further.
So he sent it back brilliantly.
And yeah.
Sitting in tech, trying out,
does she have green highlights,
does she have yellow highlights?
Does she have spots?
Does she have stripes?
And trying out
different combinations,
settling on this palette.
And brilliantly, Daisy, who
is the puppet supervisor
on the project--
Daisy Beatty, she's
amazing, she's
got many, many skills--
and Lara, who's
from the National Theatre
Props Workshop, who's
an amazing painter,
they just set
to work priming and painting
her ready for the dress
rehearsal, which is always
where the production photos are
taken, for shows really.
Which, on really
design-heavy shows,
you're like, that's crazy.
The show's not even-- we haven't
got it on its feet fully yet.
But it's when it's needed
for press and for publicity.
So she had to be
ready for that date.
And I kind of wanted to
get used to seeing her,
whether we needed to change
the color any further.
So it was sort of nail bar
going on in the props department
of painting all
these little hands,
going into quite a lot of
detail, a lot of shading,
trying to pick up all
the contours in her.
We added a little kind of an
Swarovski crystal to her eye,
to slightly give her a pupil.
I'm a big fan of puppets
of not having a fixed sort
of dot, because actually it
means that the puppet is always
looking in one fixed place.
And if you're slightly out,
it's very, very unforgiving.
And because Jiminy is on
the floor a lot of the time
and you're looking
up, you sort of
need the freedom to
go, oh, if her nose is
looking in that direction,
she's looking up there.
And it's more fun
for the audience
to kind of fill in
the blanks and imagine
what her eyes are doing.
And so the white little
crystal on top of the orange
just gives her a
little kind of accent
as to where her
kind of direction
is without being
too kind of staring
kind of Muppet-eyed
kind of black on white.
And so we ended
up with her as she
is now, her very lime
green, bright, playful self.
And yeah.
I suppose you could talk
next a little bit about how
we brought her to life.
We-- I mean you.
I just hung out
and shouted at you.
JAMES CHARLTON:
Watched and judged.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
It's a pleasure.
Is it worth saying a little bit
about your puppetry experience
before, or how you
felt as you trained,
what you trained in
originally, and then
how that's kind of progressed
into the weird world
of puppetry?
JAMES CHARLTON: Would
you like me to go first?
AUDREY BRISSON: Yes.
You go first.
JAMES CHARLTON: Great.
Well, I trained in musical
theater, predominantly.
And my first job
out of drama school
was "Les Miserables"
in the West End.
And it was amazing.
And in my second job,
I luckily met Toby.
And it was on "The
Light Princess"
at the National Theatre.
And it was my first
real experience
of puppetry in any form.
I'd sort of watched
the "Muppets"
and loved it, obviously.
Who doesn't?
But it was a real
baptism of fire
because we had a lot
of different moving
puppets in that show.
It was very, very
much like Jiminy.
There would be different
aspects going on all the time.
And I learned a lot.
And I learned very
quickly on that job.
And then I sort of
got the bug for it.
Forgive the pun-- for
just sort of picking up
an object of that sort of ilk
and trying to bring it to life.
It has a real sort
of gratification
of being able to serve
something that's beyond you
with other people at one time.
And I feel like there's
something probably
we share, as all
puppeteers, of making
something bigger than you.
And I think that's sort of
an ensemble nature anyway,
and that's sort of
what I trained in.
And then from there,
I just didn't stop.
I think I've done
puppetry jobs ever since.
And it's been a real pleasure to
do it, because it's such a joy.
And you get to do so many
different types of shows
and work in different places.
I did another show in Manchester
at the Royal Exchange.
It was in the Round,
which was just fantastic.
And we took a real
show that was sort of--
you know, Audrey II was
sort of stuck in most parts,
at the back of the stage.
But because we're in the Round,
we sort of had to change up.
And that was quite
fun-- doing something--
TOBY OLIE: Not Audrey too.
JAMES CHARLTON: Not Audrey too.
Not this Audrey.
TOBY OLIE: The big plant
from Little Shop of Horrors.
Yeah.
JAMES CHARLTON: And
then, obviously--
AUDREY BRISSON:
Who's named after me.
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
JAMES CHARLTON: A few years
later, "Pinocchio" comes round
and it was in workshop.
And it just took off from there.
What about you?
AUDREY BRISSON: Well, I also
trained in music theater.
And I find it very
funny when Toby mentions
that he wanted to work
with experienced puppeteers
because I wasn't one of them.
I mean, I have worked in the
past with Toby a little bit.
You know, I've had the odd
experience with a puppet
for two or three
minutes in the show,
and then moved away
from the puppet and--
TOBY OLIE: Just put
it down and walk away.
AUDREY BRISSON: Yeah.
I'm done now.
So when Toby called
me and said, would you
like to be part of the research
and development for Pinocchio,
playing Jiminy--
and with the line,
we don't know yet
if it's going to be a
puppet or an actor--
the nine weeks that we had for
the rehearsals of "Pinocchio"
were the training.
And actually, I believe
that regardless of how much
experience you've had,
every puppet is a new one.
TOBY OLIE: Absolutely.
AUDREY BRISSON: You
will have to figure out
the language of the
puppet that you are with.
So James and I-- well, maybe
not you, because you also do--
but like I puppeteered
Jiminy, but I would never
be able to puppeteer
Geppetto or the Blue Fairy,
because it's a completely
different instrument.
It took me the nine weeks to
learn how to play with her
and be happy.
She was very heavy.
She's not heavy, but
she was heavy for me
at the very beginning.
TOBY OLIE: Anything
is heavy if you're
holding it mid-height out
for 10, 15 minutes at a time.
You could hold a bag of-- you
could hold your iPhone out
and after a while and be
like, oh, it's a bit--
AUDREY BRISSON: Yeah.
No.
It's surprising.
So there would be a lot of, do
the scene once and then, OK,
put Jiminy aside,
relax the muscles.
Maybe do it with
your own body, just
to have a feeling of what it is
that you're trying to portray.
And at first we used
to do that quite a lot.
TOBY OLIE: Yes.
AUDREY BRISSON: And then
there was one afternoon
where we had some
children coming over
to see some of the
rehearsals that we'd done.
Because it was just to see if
the children responded to what
we were doing.
And John Tiffany, the director,
asked me to lead the warm up
with Jiminy.
So we arrived.
And it was our first time
improvising with her.
And I think it opened
the door for us
to understand that
actually, we had
more control than we thought.
We could play more
than we could.
And then afterwards,
it really was, for me,
like an overnight thing.
After this rehearsal, all
the leading of the warm up,
suddenly, we could play.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
I think there are certain
points in the rehearsal process
for puppeteers, where there's
certain benchmark moments,
where--
you first get it, and
it's absolutely foreign,
and you hate it.
No matter what it is.
It doesn't matter
how well-- yeah.
But you do, and you go,
because you want to end game,
and you always want to
get to the final product.
AUDREY BRISSON: And you're
blocked by the incapacity.
JAMES CHARLTON: And
there's a few moments
where you sort of get there.
And that was definitely
one of those moments
where you suddenly clicked, and
you go, John, the possibilities
are now endless for us.
We can sort of go
anywhere with this puppet.
But it takes a long
time to get there.
And we're fortunate,
with the National,
that they gave us such a
long period of rehearsal
to understand the puppet,
to get to know it.
And also, it's not just full
nine weeks on that one puppet.
There's so much more
going on in the room.
You know, we'll be
dancing in the morning
or learning a song
in the afternoon.
And we get an hour at the end
of the day to play with Jiminy.
AUDREY BRISSON: At
the end of the day.
It was always at
JAMES CHARLTON: Which is--
and you're sort of so tired.
I don't know if I
can do anything else.
TOBY OLIE: But even
from the outside,
you know, as a director
of the puppets,
you start off very much
talking to James and Audrey
and going, OK, so it's this,
and if you hold it there,
maybe that's easier.
And where's the tension?
How can we help that move?
And you are sort of by the
end going, OK, can Jimmy
jump up and do-- you end up
sort of talking about Jiminy
like she's a character in
the room, which she is.
She's another
performer in the room.
And actually it was so exciting
seeing, after that warm up,
you guys being
able to improvise.
And we did put the puppet down.
You know, there were times
when, if a move was tricky,
or you want to-- she's
such a small puppet on such
a big stage.
Her movements had to be quite
kind of concise, very sort of
crystallized, so that
her whole body is
kind of reacting to the same
kind of state of tension.
And very often--
did you like that?
That was good.
AUDREY BRISSON: I did.
TOBY OLIE: Wasted.
Wasted in puppetry.
That Audrey would have a
go, James would have a go.
And we'd sort of see how
it was embodied in them,
and then put that in the puppet.
And that process
sort of gradually
decreased as their
thinking went more and more
into kind of what
the puppet could do,
what was the puppet's
version of that emotion.
JAMES CHARLTON: I think
an important thing for us
as well-- we live in a sort of
a box about this big on stage
together, as two
actors or puppeteers.
So it's about getting used
to that sort of relationship
with each other.
And as well as we
know each other,
it's about sort
of literally being
able to lean on your
partner at certain points.
AUDREY BRISSON: Absolutely.
JAMES CHARLTON: And knowing
that when I barge into Audrey,
it's not because I want
her to move out the way.
It is because that's
the only way my body can
get to that certain place.
And that's a real
great relationship
that we've built
over the nine weeks.
And going forward, the teamwork
involved in it is really--
it has to be sort
of in that box.
If it's anywhere
outside there-- as
soon as you sort of have
airs and graces about it,
you're done.
AUDREY BRISSON:
In September, if I
was to take one step
to the left when
we'd said that we were
supposed to go to the right,
it would go--
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
It would go wrong.
AUDREY BRISSON:
Completely mental.
What are you doing and now--
JAMES CHARLTON: We'd have to
reassess and take about an hour
and go, why did you go left when
I was obviously going right?
AUDREY BRISSON: Yeah.
It was obviously right.
Whereas now, when I
forget my words on stage,
and I start mini-improvising
or blocking,
well, James just laughs and
just completely goes with me.
JAMES CHARLTON: I don't
completely laughed, but yes.
It is fun.
TOBY OLIE: But it is.
It's such a strange
thing, thinking
in a group of two, three,
four, as one brain.
It's a massive
test of generosity
onstage, of kind of
really good acting.
As somebody who studied puppetry
and trained in puppetry,
the more I kind of hear about
other people's acting training,
or work with more actors and
directors, great puppetry
and great acting
are kind of the same
in that you're kind of
leaving room for the audience
to project their own
experiences and emotions
on your performance.
You're not selling it
so much that you're
kind of offended by it.
And there's something really
selfless about puppetry.
Not only because
you're telling people
to look at this inanimate
thing, not at you.
But at the same
time, you kind of
have to take responsibility for
your bit of the puppet, then
your bit of the
puppet in relation
to the other person's
bit of the puppet.
Then how that puppet relates
to another character opposite.
You sort of feel
the vision goes--
and your peripheral
vision kind of
feels like a muscle by the
end, that you've really
kind of worked.
And it's just very exciting
making decisions together.
I was one of the puppeteers in
the original production of "War
Horse."
And you work in a team with
three on the horses together.
And one night we had a
light explode above us
in the sort of rig
of the theater.
A massively loud bang
in a really quiet calm,
pastoral kind of moment, and
the horses just really relaxed.
This huge bang happened.
And more fool us,
because it could've been
something huge falling on us.
None of us as puppeteers went--
and looked up.
The horse went--
and was spooked.
Because you're kind of in
this weird state together.
You're in this kind of weird,
sort of meditative state,
going, OK, yeah, we're
listening to each other.
If the feet give me a
signal, I'll do something.
But otherwise, I'll be looking.
And when you're in
that kind of state,
you're kind of taught to
react to any outside stimulus
together.
And so the fact that the horse
reacted to an exploding light,
and none of us thought about
our own lives, and looked up,
was hilarious and bizarre.
So shall we give
Jiminy a bit of a demo
and talk about some principles?
AUDREY BRISSON: Yes.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
Absolutely.
AUDREY BRISSON:
She wants her time.
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
She needs her time.
Which puppet is this, Audrey?
Which one?
AUDREY BRISSON: This
is Tracy McJumpy.
TOBY OLIE: So we've got
two puppets in the show.
And to help distinguish
them, Audrey's named them.
So yes.
This is Tracy McJumpy.
AUDREY BRISSON: And we
have Brenda MacLeapy,
who is currently on rest--
TOBY OLIE: On rest.
AUDREY BRISSON: In a spa.
TOBY OLIE: In a spa, yes.
She's having a bath somewhere.
I'll do it this time.
Don't worry.
You've got next.
So let's talk mechanics,
a little bit, actually,
who's doing what.
So Audrey has got
a rod in the back
of the body, which you can maybe
show us if you still keep her
in the character.
Yeah.
And that rod is attached to
her body with an elastic.
And Audrey has a little
trigger on that rod.
That means she can
raise her chin.
[LAUGHTER]
And then in her right
hand, Audrey's got two rods
that go from
Jiminy's arms, which
she's holding sort of like kind
of crazy reverse chopsticks.
It's a thing that took a
long, long time to practice.
That's the face of experience.
A long, long time to practice.
And sort of trusting that
you can sort of keep one
pose while you move your
finger to twist another one.
She's got these lovely little
wrist joints or hand joints
that you can twist
the stick and her hand
goes palm, top, palm, top.
And so yeah.
It's a bit of a sort of
multitasking challenge being
on the head and arms
at the same time.
And then James is on the feet.
And he's got little
rods in the back.
And all of her leg
joints are bungee.
They've all got elastic
running through them.
So that Audrey can
jump Jiminy by herself.
Yeah, go on.
So she's kind of got enough
kind of structure and bounce
to manage that.
But then James can
join in and sync up
for kind of bigger jumps,
or kind of crazier moves--
AUDREY BRISSON: [LAUGHS]
TOBY OLIE: And then
her second set of arms
are similarly bungeed,
so that she can-- yeah.
She gets very exasperated
and says, I'm a cricket!
AUDREY BRISSON: Six!
Six!
I'm not a spider?
TOBY OLIE: Very good.
Very good.
Yeah.
And so the two of
them are always
in a kind of slight tension
together as well, which again,
the elastic of the
legs really helps
be in sort of slight
tension with each other.
So that if Audrey
makes a decision,
or James makes a decision, they
can literally feel each other
through the puppet.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
And so three principles
that I kind of use,
the core ones anyway
when directing puppetry--
the first one is focus.
And all these kind of apply to
the puppeteer and the puppet
really.
But yeah.
Focus for a puppet--
where it's looking tells
you what it's interested in.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Good luck picking that up.
Oh, nearly!
Good try.
So yeah.
Where a puppet's
looking basically
tells you where the story is at.
And as puppeteers,
where they're looking
tells us what the most important
thing on stage to look at is.
If they look away, and
look at you guys, then
there's three
characters on stage.
But as soon as they
look at the puppet,
they're immediately telling
you to look at Jiminy.
In the same way--
[LAUGHTER]
No pictures.
In the same way that
if I'm talking to you
and I look at the
door and go, [GASP]
what are you all going to do?
You're going to turn
and look at the door.
Yeah.
Exactly.
We're pack animals who
instinctively do that.
And so the act of
puppeteering-- or certainly,
my preference of
puppeteering, is going
to give focus to the object.
So the audience
looks at the object.
So that's focus.
Second one is breath.
AUDREY BRISSON: I
thought I'd seen
something that was exciting.
TOBY OLIE: So if we
go watch a play--
if we go and watch Benedict
Cumberbatch in "Hamlet"--
AUDREY BRISSON: [GASP]
TOBY OLIE: I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, you like
Benedict Cumberbatch?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm pretty sure a lot of
you wouldn't go home and go,
and I saw Benedict
Cumberbatch breathing.
Like, his breathing was amazing.
I mean, you might do.
That might be your thing.
I don't know.
But with puppets, it's
sort of fundamental
that the audience
have to believe
that they're alive before
they can do anything else.
Before they can learn about
the character or the reactions,
or the emotional range,
or its physicality,
you sort of have
to start playing
the game with the audience.
And the simplest way doing
that is through breath.
It's by showing her breathing.
And the puppet, and by
Audrey vocalizing it.
[BREATHING]
And whilst James isn't
vocalizing the breath, per se,
for the audience to hear,
he's on the same kind
of breath wavelength with her.
So that you're in the
same state of tension.
And so that way breath
becomes a really useful tool
kit for the two of them to
check in with each other,
or do a little prep breath
before they do a big move
or various little bits.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It allows a kind
of synchronicity.
The third one is weight.
Which-- I mean,
you're not heavy.
AUDREY BRISSON: OK.
Thank you.
TOBY OLIE: The
simplest way of putting
it-- muscles versus
gravity, in that,
without any weight or
muscularity, if Jiminy jumps,
he's just sort of lifting off.
Well that was too good.
You did it with one.
Go on.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDREY BRISSON:
That's too-- wait--
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
Exactly.
But with our muscles
versus gravity,
there's kind of more of a prep.
Go on.
Do it.
Try and give us it again.
[GASP]
You know, it's as
simple as that.
You're kind of giving
the puppet our physics,
essentially, because a
puppet can do anything.
It can fly.
It can explode apart.
I've done that
with some puppets.
[LAUGHTER]
But with Jiminy we
do little things.
She slightly suspends
her gravity sometimes
if she's shouting
stop, or she does--
AUDREY BRISSON: Stop!
[LAUGHTER]
TOBY OLIE: But generally,
for the audience
to sympathize and
relate to the character,
we're giving the
puppet our physics.
So we feel its truth
and its reality.
And I suppose, weight
for the puppeteer,
my preference is
that the puppeteer,
you never see their muscles
working before the puppet's.
So that if Jiminy walks
to the edge of the table,
they get to their full
stretch before they
have to tilt and move as well.
Yeah.
You see, so James only
gets up at the last second.
If Jiminy was to
walk to the edge
of the table and
the first thing you
saw was James do that,
you'd start to second guess
what she's going to do.
And there's a big
thing about putting
the audience in the
brain of the puppet
by letting the puppet
instigate all of the movements.
Should we give them
a bit of repertoire?
A bit of scene?
I'll stand in for
everybody else in the scene
and be a bit of an
eyeline by standing here.
And you can watch
her do her thing.
AUDREY BRISSON: Are you ready?
JAMES CHARLTON: Yes.
AUDREY BRISSON: OK.
What's going on?
Wait?
Who are you?
Why am I talking?
Is it cold in here?
Oh, yes, I think
it's cold in here.
Is this my voice?
Well, it's a bit high, isn't it?
[GASP]
Have I got a throat infection?
Oh, I do feel a bit weird.
Maybe I'm coming
down with something.
Am I coming down with something?
I think I'm coming
down with something.
Achoo!
Oh no.
I'm coming down with something.
This table is filthy.
Why is that window open?
Do you have any idea how much
the temperature drops at night?
I mean, has no one heard of
streptococcal pharyngitis?
Ugh.
Right.
So.
In my first official
act as your conscience,
I declare that it
is time for bed.
But I said it's time for bed.
Ugh.
Look.
You heard the lady.
I'm your conscience, which
means I know what's best.
And I am telling you
that it is time for bed.
Oof!
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
Well, I'm off then.
TOBY OLIE: Nice.
Very good guys.
Very good, very good.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
So yeah.
So the character of
Jiminy in the show
is slightly more kind of
hypochondriac, slightly more
OCD, slightly more,
forgive me, annoying sort
of sibling to Pinocchio than the
sort of wiser, older guardian
sort of Yoda vibe that he
is in the animated film.
So it's been really fun kind
of letting that character
kind of develop, and finding
your version of Jiminy
throughout rehearsal.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
The puppet tells us slightly
more about the character
than sometimes the writing can.
Because it can only
do x or y, which
leads us to do certain things.
Or it can do a myriad
of different things,
and it means that the
possibilities are endless
and we shouldn't just be honed
in to what's on the script
sometimes.
TOBY OLIE: And because she's
turned from a real cricket
into our kind of
anthropomorphic cricket, her--
do her chirruping, what that
transition is from [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY BRISSON: Chirrup.
TOBY OLIE: So she
starts the cricket.
AUDREY BRISSON: Chirrup.
Shutup.
Shut up.
TOBY OLIE: So she becomes
really kind of angsty.
And so every so often, a kind
of cricketism sort of kicks in,
a bit like a sort of tic.
We sort of gave her this kind
of little like leg stem--
AUDREY BRISSON: Shut up.
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
Yeah, see.
We don't need a puppet.
They're in sync.
Practically married.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And so it was really
interesting finding
how her kind of cricketiness
kicks in at moments
of stress or tension.
But yeah.
That is how we brought Jiminy
Cricket to life in "Pinocchio."
AUDIENCE: What is the difference
between bringing puppetry
to stage versus
bringing it to screen?
Kind of what's the
different processes
that you would go
through for that?
TOBY OLIE: I have a lot
more prep time in theater
than in screen.
Certainly with sort of puppetry
in TV and film that I've done,
there's a lot of making time.
But actually the
sort of development
and having the time on set
to practice things-- it's
very much on the day.
You find something,
you work together,
and it's kind of
onscreen doing its thing.
Whereas, yeah, on "Pinocchio"
we had nine weeks rehearsal,
plus workshop time before that?
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
TOBY OLIE: It feels like you're
kind of slightly chipping
away and growing and developing
it, whereas in the film,
it's very much
like, this is here.
It's on the day.
Let's do it.
And very often with
film and TV puppetry,
you're only a part
of the picture.
It's going to be
filled in with CGI,
or it's going to have
another element to it.
Or the puppeteers
will be taken away.
There's always kind
of another process,
whereas it feels,
certainly in theater,
it's very much like, you're
building towards that finished
thing as a long term goal.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
AUDREY BRISSON: And also,
once you film, you filmed it
and then you move on,
whereas we've been performing
since early December.
And literally an
hour ago, we were
talking to Toby
about this new idea
that we could add something
at the end of the show.
We are way ahead of where we
were in December, already,
so this is constant.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
Totally.
And I suppose it's like you say.
It's the filling in the gaps,
whereas with stage, it's
got to be ready to go.
It's got to be film ready,
as it were, every night,
for x amount of months.
Whereas with film you can
sort of take it back, edit it,
someone else can fill
in the gaps for you.
We sort of have to do it all.
That's why we're so good.
AUDREY BRISSON: We are.
Yeah.
TOBY OLIE: And modest.
[LAUGHTER]
Who knew.
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking about what
it must have taken
to choreograph
every second of that scene,
that short scene you just did.
And I wondered if you could
talk a little bit about how you
find your path through that.
Are there moments that
you kind of mentally map
and go, OK, so we want that
movement, that movement,
that movement, that one,
and you connect them all up?
Or is it a bit more fluid?
Like how do you find
your way through that?
It must just take so long.
AUDREY BRISSON: Well today
was already a bit of a mash up
and improvisation on the theme.
Because I'm usually on the
table, the other way around.
Having said that, yes.
It is still choreographed
every night.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
There's a certain amount
of being choreographed.
And there's also got to
be fluidity, because it's
a live theater project.
If you were just rigid
and stuck in what you do,
I feel like the only
thing that would suffer
would be the puppetry.
We have quite a good
dynamic in that sense,
as I like to keep the structure.
And Audrey will not
keep the structure.
AUDREY BRISSON: I
would like to, I just--
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CHARLTON: Because Audrey's
also got about three balls
to juggle.
And I've only got one.
So moments can
get lost, but it's
my job to follow and
listen as much as possible.
And Audrey's job is to offer
up different situations.
And between the
two of us, we can
get through a show
pretty competently now.
AUDREY BRISSON: Yeah.
JAMES CHARLTON: But that
takes time to develop.
But there are
earmarks in the script
that we go, well, these are
the lines we've got to say.
And that's usually
how we say them.
But it can be a bit more fluid.
AUDREY BRISSON: And
I think it comes back
to what we were saying earlier.
In the early days,
it was very important
for us to follow
said choreography.
And now we have a
bit more freedom.
And it will also be
a tell on whether we
are having a good show or not.
Sometimes we are
very, very in tune
and we listen to each other--
TOBY OLIE: It's
all coming out now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDREY BRISSON: No, no.
And we'll find moments
where you can go,
wow, we improvised that
bit, because something
had gone wrong, but we were so
together, that it was seamless,
whereas other moments,
you know, I'll be ahead,
or I'll be behind.
Or you'll feel
slightly disconnected.
It never happens.
Don't worry.
Sometimes it happens.
TOBY OLIE: Thanks guys.
I think what's interesting
is having the script first,
certainly as an outsider,
finding the character with you
guys--
you sort of look for the
changes in emotional tension.
And with her, it was
sort of about finding
what kind of shapes
would read, given
that for people at the
back of the auditorium,
she's probably a little green
speck, sort of that big.
No offense.
And it sort of became
about sort of using those
as kind of chapter headings--
new changes of thought,
things like that,
where the kind of
flight plan map of her
emotionally is in that scene.
And having that as
a kind of structure.
Very often with
puppetry, you end up sort
of saying, there's a kind
of visual script of moves
that you know are the
kind of lines, I guess,
that the puppet
has to go through.
But how you say them, in
what temperature, in what--
AUDREY BRISSON: Dynamic.
TOBY OLIE: Emotion, what
frequency-- yeah, dynamic--
is sort of always up for grabs.
I suppose I'm always
keen, and these guys
do it amazingly-- all the
puppeteers on "Pinocchio"
do it amazingly-- of not
filling in any intentional gaps.
Because pauses are really
clear, as you would have seen.
You know, if she
looks at something,
there's a kind of
little moment for you
all to clock that she's
looking, or maybe make
sense of what she thinks of it.
And actually, with puppetry,
all those tiny gaps--
the more you do something,
those tiny gaps feel massive.
You feel like you're kind
of giving dead air time.
And so very often, puppets
start to go quite hyper,
or kind of overact, because
other bits start to tune in.
And there's a real discipline
in going, actually,
those pauses or little kind
of moments where you just
see breath, are all
there for the audience
to kind of read in and apply
understanding and movement
and meaning.
And if they're
taken away, you're
kind of bombarding the
audience with information.
So it feels like quite
a good discipline
to kind of keep
that sense of play,
whilst having a sort
of outside perspective
on what you guys would be
thinking of what they're doing.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
TOBY OLIE: It's a weird thing.
When you're a puppeteer, you
are actor and your own director
at the same time.
You have to sort of develop
your own outside eye, which
is a strange thing, but
a really satisfying thing
when it kicks in.
AUDREY BRISSON: It
really is, especially
when you have someone
like Toby here,
who is an amazing director,
because he knows what he wants.
But he's also very
good at saying,
when I come with a problem
going, in the early days,
how do I hold her, or how do
I do this particular movement,
because I don't know how
to physically do it--
and he's like, just work it out.
TOBY OLIE: Work it out, lazy.
AUDREY BRISSON: No,
but meaning, you're--
and it's the best way to do it.
Because we do find
our way of doing it.
And he's not going to be very
prescriptive about when she
needs to breathe or turn right.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
AUDREY BRISSON: Then Jiminy
becomes our own character.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
And ultimately it's
about storytelling.
And Toby is a very
good storyteller.
And that's helpful when you're
being directed in puppetry,
that it's very clearly about
the story, rather than anything
else.
Because you can get--
I mean, we could do some
amazing tricks with Jiminy.
But it wouldn't help
the story at all.
AUDREY BRISSON: It's not-- yeah.
TOBY OLIE: And it's funny.
Because in rehearsals
at the beginning,
very often, if Audrey was
like, how would this happen,
I'd sort of go, well, let's
see, and kind of do it.
And she'd go, God,
how could you do that?
AUDREY BRISSON: Because his
hand is like three times
as big as mine!
TOBY OLIE: How can you move
the thing-- yeah, that's true.
[LAUGHTER]
And you'd be like, maybe
it's this, maybe it's that.
You make a suggestion.
But halfway through rehearsals,
they are masters of it.
And I'd go, well,
let me give it a go.
Ahh!
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
It is sort of this
weird thing of,
you learn how to work with this
object so kind of tactiley--
our puppets are more
like musical instruments
than my props.
Whenever I go into a
new project and people
want to use puppetry,
I'm always like, solve
who the puppeteers are, first.
Then you'll know what
the kind of world is.
Who are the people that are
invisible in your aesthetic?
And second of all, think of
them as musical instruments,
because they're expensive
in man hours to make.
They need stands.
They need fine tuning.
They need someone
to look after them.
We've got a puppet technician,
full time on the show,
whose job is to just
look after the puppets.
An amazing guy, Will.
Yeah.
It's really interesting,
how sort of bespoke,
and the kind of relationship
the kind of bond
you have with this object.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Me.
AUDIENCE: OK, here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you talk to us
a little bit more
about how you guys work
together so closely over such
a long period of time?
There can't be many
other jobs where
you're so stuck to
someone else for so long.
So I'm really curious as to--
is that just part of
being a puppeteer?
Or do you have to do specific
exercises to get used
to one another's movements?
JAMES CHARLTON: I think--
I'll take this
one, just quickly.
AUDREY BRISSON: Please do.
JAMES CHARLTON: It's
just in my head.
It's different
with every puppet.
And it's different
with every job.
And with every single person
that you puppeteer with.
Ultimately, everyone's
got the same goal,
which is always really great.
And I think in any type
of business, crossover
anywhere, if everyone's got
the same goal and same aim,
you're usually going to
be on the same track.
The difficulty is always
working with other people,
because everyone has different
needs, even though you're
aiming for the same thing.
But I feel like, especially
with our relationship,
it's about understanding
who we are as people first.
And then making sure
that that serves the goal
at the end of the day.
Sometimes we're
selfless with that.
Yourself, certainly.
And myself.
It's about letting go of
who you are and going, OK,
we can put that aside.
And let's just get
on with the job.
But it can be difficult.
It can be difficult.
But I feel like creating a
good relationship between us
means that, when
we go on stage, we
don't have to worry about that.
We can just do the job.
And if we've got concerns,
we can speak to each other.
There's no problems there.
Being very open and honest
about stuff is really important,
I think.
AUDREY BRISSON: And, you know,
I think we are very fortunate,
because when you
see, potentially,
other people who are not in such
a fortunate relationship, no--
I think, James and I,
I'm very fortunate.
So thank you very much.
I can be a little
bit like Jiminy.
I can be a bit angsty
and stressed and nervous.
I'm going to use different words
to say exactly the same thing.
Whereas James is very good at
calming situations, and being
laid back in a way.
And I think that's what works.
There are moments on stage when
it's not physically dangerous.
But I'm in a slightly
precarious position.
And people quite
often tell me, when
after seeing the show,
how much they notice
James being focused on me.
I mean, of course,
he's on the puppet.
But you can feel
that he's there.
He protects me.
He's aware.
No.
You do!
[LAUGHTER]
But people have noticed.
And there are moments when
he's just aware that maybe--
JAMES CHARLTON: And then there's
times when I want to push you.
AUDREY BRISSON: Oh yes.
Yes, he does.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CHARLTON: And
it's dangerous thinking.
AUDREY BRISSON: So we
are very fortunate.
Because we could
hate each other.
And I guess it's like any job.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So it is very fortunate.
But it's like any acting job.
Very, very, very
early on, on day one,
the creatives are going
to be working hard
at making you feel
comfortable with each other.
We are literally all over
each other on day one.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
AUDREY BRISSON:
The hands on face.
JAMES CHARLTON: But
also, it comes down
to Toby's choice of
puppeteers and team.
Because you know
everybody personally.
And like you said, you
want the experience.
But also, Toby knows everyone
personally, in a personal way,
as either friends
or as colleagues.
He knows the type of
temperament of people.
So I'm sure in the back of his
head, I can't speak for him,
but there is a moment where
he goes-- that will work.
That will work.
And that will work.
And not always
will it come to it.
But I imagine, most of the time.
AUDREY BRISSON: And also,
as you were saying earlier,
how you are very consistent.
And I'm not.
It's a good marriage.
JAMES CHARLTON: Yeah.
AUDREY BRISSON: Because then
we find the air around Jiminy,
which--
JAMES CHARLTON: We gel.
AUDREY BRISSON: We gel.
AUDREY BRISSON: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBY OLIE: Yeah.
I think it's very often about
kind of relinquishing control
as well, and sort of going,
I trust that the other person
is going to do that.
So finding the sort of
combinations of teams
for these puppets in the show.
We knew the people who
are operating the heads
and doing the voices were
cast as those characters.
But of the kind of squad of
six, seven puppeteers-- seven,
eight puppeteers--
it was up for grabs who
was on which character.
So very much a lot of the
early rehearsals and the puppet
training, we're sort
of going, right,
do we put a lot of the
"War Horse" veterans
with the really
experienced person
who was in "The Lion King"?
Do we put quite a few of
the people who never touched
a puppet before
together, so they all
have those
realizations together,
so that nobody is sort of
going, guys, it's like this.
And actually--
AUDREY BRISSON: Ohhh.
TOBY OLIE: Ohhh.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CHARLTON:
That's how it works.
TOBY OLIE: And with these
two, it was exactly that.
I was like, Audrey is
already great at Jiminy.
Has a lot of self-doubt.
Will be absolutely fantastic.
James is a kind of--
is just so organized
and self-critical
and consistent,
that actually the two
of them together are
kind of the yin to
each other's yang.
And so kind of watching
Jiminy kind of--
come together and
kind of form and
throughout that whole
process was just amazing.
AUDIENCE: Give Toby a
massive round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]